whoever's in last place whoever that
person is if there was a world chart
ranking and Sally was dead last she can
talk I don't know how to get people out
of depression I'm just trying to change
people's perspective
[Music]
gratitude is my fuel I think most people
burn out because they're looking for
money I think people are depressed when
they don't have things into context they
don't realize how lucky they have it and
to they don't feel in control when the
game itself and the process and
gratitude is the mix of your gasoline
you'll run forever I've only won d-roc
this games Vig I already won I figured
myself out I know what makes me happy
nothing in the world makes me happier
everybody is the happiest when they get
to do what they want to be doing when
you get to do what you want to do you've
won
I think the problem is that people get
to a place where they don't want to go
backwards because they get fancy right
they get accustomed to a certain
lifestyle they want certain things when
it's about getting a watch or buying a
new home or having a new pair of Yeezys
you're finished and I will tell you the
number one thing that scares the [ __ ]
out of me
nice watches and Ferraris so I see a lot
of people looking for quick highs that
is just not sustainable glass half-empty
is a terrible way to live life
this is foolish [ __ ] for me I know
exactly what to do with what's in there
I know exactly what the [ __ ] to do with
this and other people don't know what to
do with a full [ __ ] container Antonio
man you're [ __ ] entitled if you ever
in your life bought a five-dollar
[ __ ] coffee from Starbucks
you are [ __ ] soft globally in the
seven point seven billion people your
[ __ ] fancy your soft fifty million
people that came from dick [ __ ] and
[ __ ] made it so what the [ __ ] your
Excuse both my parents were crackheads
and like uh I lost my job and my
husband's beating me and I'm not [ __ ]
saying these are small things these are
the hardest things in life here's my
question
life's about alternatives what the [ __ ]
are you gonna do about nobody has
anything to complain about unless you're
the worst human on earth in the world
rankings of humans you're seven point
seven billion you live in a cage and
you're asleep somewhere where nobody's
looking because that's who that person
is well let's do that person
complaining my stuff is for the
complainers who don't realize they have
time to fix it they just have to change
their behavior kick a plane about your
weight if you didn't put in the work you
may be genetically disposition to not
have as great of a body or be as healthy
and that's just life and that's real but
I wasn't allowed to complain about my
health at 37 I wasn't doing the right
things or you can sit at home play
[ __ ] 2k and blame the world for your
shortcomings period brother people don't
want to work you know why it's easier to
complain the religion baby like you like
but if you don't complain and you then
you've won you can do it any way you
want make a dollar eater make up all the
dollars in a year
you've won it's not about that spend
every minute with your kids spend no
minutes with their kids if you're happy
and you don't complain you've won
[Music]